that's still getting no because I think
a lot of people obviously still worry
that they might have the the symptoms
and so it quite rightly they're calling
either 1 1 1 or an extremists the the
ambulance service but you still see a
steady fall in the number of hospital
admissions not just in London but
throughout the country and a steady fall
in the number of deaths so we have got
the virus really very much under control
across the country but we need to keep
it there and that's why were continuing
to take every possible precaution
well it's something that I came to
understand and care about very very much
1012 years ago when I was started to run
Transport for London I became aware of
the the insults the aggression that are
directed towards people who work in in
in the impact me great public service
like transport all the London and alert
service all the police come to that and
I really think that our amazing
ambulance workers they do deserve for
all emergency services they deserve
proper protection from people who are
going to be abusive or racist or
prejudiced in in any way and that's why
we're increasing the sentences were
doubling the potential sentence for
those who are violent towards people who
are trying after all to save their lives
musk yes are you going to make it
compulsory to wear masks in shops in
England than anywhere else that it's
currently not what we've said for a
while now is that we do think that masks
have a great deal of value obviously the
mandatory on public transport on the
tube but they have a regular value in
confined spaces where you're meeting you
come into contact with people you don't
normally meet and what's been
interesting on the face coverings issue
in the last few months is that the
scientific sort of evaluation of face
coverings and and their importance in
stopping aerosol droplets that's been
growing and so I do think that in shops
it is very important to wear a face
covering if you're going to be in a
confined space and you want us to
protect other people and to receive
protection in turn yes face coverings I
think people should be wearing in shops
and in terms of how we do that how
whether we make it mandatory or not
we'll be looking at the the guidance
we'll be saying a little bit more in in
the next few days Thanks well I think
that as throughout this crisis people
have shown amazing sensitivity towards
other people and to and understanding of
the needs to to get the virus down by
doing things cooperatively and I think
wearing masks is one of them in in a
confined space what you're doing is
you're protecting other people from the
from the transmission that you might be
giving often they in turn are protecting
you so it's it's a mutual thing people
do see the value of it and will be will
be looking in the next few days about
exactly how you know with what with what
tools of enforcement we think we want to
to make progress but I think as the
virus comes down in incidents and we
have more more success
I think face coverings are a kind of
extra insurance that we can all use to
stop it coming back and stop it getting
out of control again we'll be seeing a
little bit more Sam in the in the next
few days but but just to be absolutely
clear I do think that face coverings
have a real value in confined spaces and
and I think the public to understand
what we're seeing if you talk to
businesses you talk to companies around
the country whether it's the the the
pubs and the restaurants that have been
opening Apple or all public service
spaces like this people have gone to
huge lengths office office spaces people
gone to huge lengths to make their
businesses kovat secure so that
installing washing facilities are
installing screens are installing social
distancing measures doing all sorts of
things to make the workplace safe and
what I want to see is people now who've
been working from home for a long time
now talking to their employers talking
to their place work about the steps that
there had been taken and looking to come
back to work in a safe way in a safe way
and I think that's that's got to be the
key thing it's where business has made a
huge effort to make the workplace safe I
do think people should start to think
about getting back to work but provided
we all continue to follow the
precautions number one of which still
remains mean not just face coverings it
is washing you your hands
- big brexit connected announcements now
that's what you spent for 30 billion
pounds propping up the economy but today
you as the government awarding that
bracket might push up costs whether it's
roaming fees or insurance when you go
abroad or there's been like can be
friction at the ports and we're asking
people to prepare for that why are you
making you think she probably warm hand
when you're admitting things to get more
expensive well I mean I think one of the
amazing things about the last few few
months about the the whole Cove aid
crisis is it I think it's put all those
questions very much into perspective and
actually I don't think that I never have
thought that the the so-called you know
project fear with brexit whatever
materializing quite the way that people
some people did I do think there are big
opportunities for this country to do
things differently and do things better
but obviously we have to get ready to
for the end of the transition period in
in in December January and and get it
done we know we've come out of the EU
we've we've delivered on that and we're
gonna deliver on coming out of the
transition period as well by the end of
the year and all we're saying is that
there will be changes people should get
ready but there'll also be great
opportunities for this country you are
setting immigration proposals a lot of
talk has been around their social allow
people to come from abroad to work in
the social care system
lowest salary why are you asking
potential suppose of Social Care
employees to coming pay the visa fee pay
the NHS don't really think there's gonna
be enough people coming in to work in
our social care system at a critical
time well I do and don't forget Sam one
of the amazing things that we've seen in
the last few months is actually there
are more EU nationals I'm proud to say
living in and working in this country
than we even thought and I think that
the numbers you know where were three
million and three point two and three
point four and we're you know we're
seeing huge numbers of people
registering for their their right to
remain and that's that's great so we
have a big big stock of of of workers
who who are helping out in this country
who have come from abroad but also
although of course we are going to be
taking back control we are controlling
our our immigration system we're not
going to be just simply slamming the the
gates and stopping anybody anywhere are
coming into this country where people
can contribute to this country where
people want to make their lives and do
great things for this country of course
we're going to have a humane and
sensible system and on the on the NHS
what were what we've already said is if
people work in the NHS then they won't
pay the the NHS surcharge and on on
people working in the care sector don't
forget that this is the government that
not only introduced the living wage but
has just put up the living wage by a
record amount we wanted that we were
gonna and to say nothing of the
investments that we're going to make and
a happy making in the social care sector
we do want to look after social care we
want to look after people who work in
our social care sector and make sure
that they are properly paid should they
consider going
I think this is a great great year for
people to have a staycation this country
is uniquely blessed with fantastic
places to holiday weather coastal or
otherwise and I'm certainly going to be
doing that that I won't
I won't necessarily tell you we're at
this stage but I think I think but
that's knowing people obviously people
feel the need for for our foreign
holiday then then that's completely
amount of them I totally understand it
but there are fantastic and tastic
places pierless wonderful superlative
places in in the UK to go on holiday and
that is certainly what I will be doing